hmm it's good to be with you this week
and today and I want to take about 15
minutes just to share with you some of
our experiences in working with data and
metrics federal and state governments
and more importantly what we've learned
from the experiences of others less this
year my gun well that's what I'm asking
I don't think it doesn't sound like I'm
a lot number four I can also bellow I
have two girls all right it's not that
were coming George sorry i'll be loved
this is I want to start really by
acknowledging that we live in data
overload this is no surprise no secret
banga how can we possibly focus and
prioritize we have tremendous focus on
monitoring a watch so I was described as
a burden that we deal with monitoring
and evaluation and a focus on these
metrics and despite the good efforts of
many we find ourselves swimming in this
sea of often a mediocre data right
Vincent implicated perhaps irrelevant
not tied directly to the metrics that
were most interested in and so we need
to work together to focus on a key set
of metrics of indicators that will serve
us well that we can measure well and
that we can use really have cross the
strategic problem solve do they're not
old 84 mother I efficient away in the
beginning now clearly and a clip
replying identify all that you want to
come doing a systematic strategy like
ultimate imports doing fine a jerk like
I feel wait
we use it to help in any position to
help lots of reasons to focus our part
of the pop the reasons behind earth of
service is the gentle unprinted include
up but there are others I think that a
challenge and it's a lack of good day to
night design / have insufficient or
inappropriate at the tip and the surface
of our challenge this creates a couple
when we first talked to put on my name
and I'm Peter no no that's mean life so
let it denominator very some of us lady
Oh estimate so as we think about a
pirate hunting among the rest of it we
some way to look at their RC fishery
they open the first and most
fundamentally about Eli and Vince attend
to a large on quality offense and your
profound sodimm limited data I healthly
and we can put the bait about this novel
place be popular for a tub
you really think Kate I'm out tourniquet
form it like qualitative
I just took remodel Oh
if he's also great honorees we get to do
more work on validation by my special
instrument built if they say shut up i'm
thinking of salaries I'm into a great
kind of self-education i regulate
something I'm very passionate they give
a damn it myself I'm going to regulate
and go to next bullet our shader well as
it's very straightforward but not too
easy bet you just great if he'll be half
page without a suit versus teacher wait
okay that's it virgin increase yea big
[ __ ] out we're going to be okay well
tell us whether we achieve this whole it
using a hawk think the battery and
starting at third or the data oak ended
catfishing up to be found limited
information and proposed verification
courted better on this site you did we
all think frost about alternative in the
translation is too personal data to shed
light on front to help Oh in faith and
our just about embedding Qaeda and
efficient it's looking at that junction
uh are fed up the tank this a daisy
chain over the antenna issue factor
filling up with honey about
okay okay dark perfect felt great sick
not purple process it do this in our up
and possibly can I mother's dupe very
early on breaks it into a I'll poke an
agent of the Act semental and
compatibility wife over here and then
lastly on event day of your ending that
event up that is distinct and holder
place think about the bill advection
deflection Sophie are mindful
Hippocratic I'll write it at some times
have you asked for it my data collection
method a life we also can ha I think
just [ __ ] pickup bed did it [ __ ]
Shepherd it right
cheap great this requires several hey
you that are better left that are seek a
credible than health care adapted and
there will be enough on the junk
Angelica come back so you create your AP
help us to think about help defend my
tmobile mask to purchase to thank you in
for broad other sources of intelligence
or Asian assessing see you Thank and the
first it can be useful to affect
political filter pump in and I think I
had a pet but all are okay up up to my
neck wait Danny loop uncle Richard but
syntactic I'm gonna have to cut out
house now remember child this big c need
this well you're giving her hope the way
oh oh come on bruh Holly and look how
beautiful David
we all want to be mindful of input at
the unelected help that's a bell shape
the landscape great so don't execute
[ __ ]
then the last sort of point too many
mate with this illustration it's that
the limp dick is at a price of this far
away and so there are infinite number of
metrics that we can choose baby be done
so it becomes important that you know
ultimately we need to focus again on
this piece set of priorities metrics
that we can have confidence and that we
can measure well and we can apply i also
want to invite us to consider
alternative sources of data and
innovative methods of data collection so
you know use of pas and cell phones for
frontline gathering of data on the front
lines you know tremendous potential here
I'm actually having a response to this
picture of this android phone what my
husband is a software developer and so
he bought us these android phone and i
use it safe online I can answer it I'm
hang up on bed to comment I send these
rain emails like blank emails because
there's a button that just I can't watch
oops opinion of bite so very important
to invest obviously the training no
question again is dr. Marple and I had
time on sunday it's like messenger some
wonderful story and the scale of the YT
is nice phenomenal training 500 health
workers in the field to use computer
cell and you describe them as computer
phone you know so this is no easy task
but certainly has tremendous potential
and I think we want everybody's watching
wanda bones for help what's going to
happen here as this rolls out how will
this actually work you know we have a
brilliant md PhD student here with
exactly this interest lewis so i hope
these had time to talk with the
wonderful filters and then lastly of
course we need to build and sustain our
human capital reason this is critical we
can have technologies and plums and
ideas of how the fixed set of metrics
but we need it
pasty and so the first thing really
imperative is an inventory of our
talents and limitations what does the
human capital workforce look like
relatives data we've just gone through
this research skilled inventory Anor ghl
I group you know who is good at what
where our strengths where r limitation
we don't have any limitation nothing
right you know where do we need to grow
where do I need to build our capacities
in the choice Kimberly be incredibly
helpful we also want to thinking of
statistics is one thing and building the
pathway and statistics and in
qualitative methods of participatory
model these are skills but indeed
collection I think we have some room to
move we can be a little creative I was
involved a little bit in a project
focused on frail older adults home mount
in a community you know high risk for
depression and this group developed an
intervention where they trade the
deliverers of the meals of the hot meals
we're trained to do a two item
depression screenings on scale highly
reliable and almost you know that have
done and I'm going to share that pic
with Angela videos so thinking broadly
about our resources we also of course
need to invest in our capacity building
and at multiple levels and at all at the
same time you know individual training
in groups and teams and facility level
training end and more oil and system and
these things need to run in tandem and
we can't really do one without the other
dr. Bartlett talks about the ramp up of
IT there it was happening all at once
you know individual levels and system
building and getting the pcs out to the
and then lastly if we decide and I think
we want to think about this other page
to embed data collection and delivery
and financing systems who really need to
engage those partners it's really very
upright early on very clearly you know
where they believe that the metrics are
relevant to their work or their credible
where the day are
back a timely way she really can have
that partnership with data collectors
any fuel so all about criteria can help
us I want to close with sort of one
observation David Burke you know we work
a lot to birth and he always encourages
us with these tensions right out on the
table so i wanted i should add your
policy makers and researchers I think we
should we share this tension experience
tension in needing data and yet not
wanting to share it when we need
benchmark needed in order to assess our
current state and determine our progress
for our goals so it's risky to share it
that's rusia on many levels the evidence
performance data may discredit a program
or policy or person so we need to aspire
it into a culture where we have data
transparent this is no easy task there
are things I think we can do to foster
data transparency to my mind again I'm
going to have impulse-control forever
let's talk more about this but happy to
talk about it in any other place and in
our workshop a little bit i'll be
working with your in group strong
reproducible science you know use of
good measurement technology and
appropriate methods methods that are
suitably aligned to the metric we're
trying to measure this is imperative as
a foundation audit capability and
systems very important you know in our
work nobody wants to build the audit
trail it's like dirty housework nobody
wants to do but we do it have to do it
and you know this is a duty in my view
here to create comprehensive clear audit
trails where we have primary data
hosting collection adjustments and all
of the assumptions that underlie
information is all of these things
clearly felt spelled out brothers to
review this could be very helpful to
fostering a sense of trust
and then lastly this is the hardest to
do I think but you create a non-punitive
environment where problems challenges
you are really viewed as opportunities
for learning where we have this shared
you of learning from our mistakes this
is not easy either we have struggles
bumps in the road in our research I've
had a few lately where I'm like this and
then I calculate its learning
opportunity to learning opportunity
learning out what's true things but this
is important to really embrace these
challenges and learn how to improve
going forward difficult to do I am going
to pause and thank you and then I want
to just let you know too that people
seem interested when Pierre salivate
pointed to some references and resources
and so I added this stuff to my slides
incentive to be prized eleven o'clock
last night and I get emails back right
away from Ryan and Dave oh it's okay
it's no problem Leslie will have all of
these articles one hundred slides fixed
and wealth all of these articles in
electronic form for the delegates up
friday but these are useful papers are
useful to me jobs in our work there's a
little series of for the lancet that are
useful in a couple of others and the
bulletin WHL so these will be in a
cd-rom it should be gained as your party
gift so I got traded over to Harlan
thank you for your attention early